foreign
foreign
foreign
the three Muslims today we're joined
with a very special guest but before I
get to that I have a very important
announcement to make unfortunately
brother fried cannot make it uh to the
stream today because his grandfather
passed away
um may Allah have mercy on him his
grandfather was a person who was the
head of his household is very close to
all of his family and he always Strokes
to get closer to Allah it's Allah and he
passed away very recently in his sleep
very peacefully so may Allah have mercy
on him and Grant him the highest levels
of Jannah and allow him to reunite with
his family there Allah I mean
we ask everybody to please give sincere
Dua for Fire's family and his
grandfather inshallah
and with that being said
today we're joined with uh Iron Man
himself he might be saying he looks a
little different this is the real Iron
Man Allah Mubarak not the fake CGI one
Robert Downey Jr this is Brother
assalamu alaikum my man how you doing
well happy to be here speak to my
brother
um it's already started bro uh
iron countdown training Iron Man since
we started a little bit late iron delay
training oh my goodness The Roasting us
already they they're already beginning
Muslim Iron Man Allah so why why do
people call you Iron Man
ah dude I think okay so let's just start
with um my real name is Hugo basali I'm
not an Iron Man or I it's a joke that
started maybe I would say maybe three
four months ago I I'll bring I'll bring
it for you guys here one second oh God I
think I know what he's bringing
I think I
yeah
basically
I had this bucket of rice and I I I'm
like I'm a pretty lean dude I'm pretty
lean for so my veins kind of show and
this is why I think maybe the videos
popped up but the video reached up like
like 7.4 million views it was me
literally saying I'm just squeezing the
hell out of rice for 15 seconds and I
was I was squeezing rice uh I saw
Chinese people like monks training in
China and they would basically squeeze
rice to strengthen the forearms and I'm
a boxer I've been boxing for around
three months so I was like why not add
this into my training and video blew up
and they started calling me iron I I do
anything I'd eat an onion they'd be like
higher onion training training I I smile
iron smiling train
I don't know
that's hilarious bro so I mean what what
got you started on the whole I I want to
call it self-improvement but nowadays
you seem to be doing a lot of things
that a lot of people would see as like
really pushing your limits even like
eating an onion why are you eating
onions and and really pushing your
boundaries these days
okay so I mean I just want to like start
it off from the beginning I've always
been like uh since the age of 15 I got
bullied a lot I would get bullied a lot
uh constantly they used to call me so my
name's hewa they used to call me hee haw
hee haw hee haw like a donkey and and
bro I would get roasted I'm 15 years old
I'm a young kid I I I was I was sad I I
was skinny as heck like if you even
right now like I'm I'm pretty I'm pretty
lean on like uh one 170 and I'm a pretty
lean guy like I can see my six-pack and
everything back then it was I was just
sticking bones just just Bone and Skin
and so I would get bullied it used to
call me Hee Haw so I'd literally just be
on my bed just doing push-ups I couldn't
do a push-up on the ground so I'd be
doing push-up wait one two three just in
my in the back of my mind I would get a
lot in a lot of fights after that like I
started doing push-ups I was tired of
getting bullied I was getting they would
call me this call me that push me okay
I'm gonna start doing push-ups and I'm
gonna get strong and honestly did lead
to a lot of uh fights and I ended up uh
getting transferred to a couple
different schools
and then it just kind of transfer
transferred into High School uh in in
high school I was dead lifting really
heavy weights it felt really good to
lift heavy uh I got rid into
weightlifting I played football but my
parents kind of kicked me out and then
just recently these past
I guess you could you could say maybe
three years
um I started doing push-ups really
consistently I did there was a period of
time in my life where I was doing like
500 push-ups a day for a month I'm
telling you my CH my chest has never
looked better I I had shoulder
impingement for around
say two years I went to a physio I went
to doctors I was benching my mind you I
got the injury due to overwork I was
over training it was ego lifting have
you ever like ego lifted before like oh
yeah oh yeah okay I was I was ego
lifting and uh I was just putting on the
weight every single day 225 I would feel
the pain but I would continue and then
at one point I just couldn't lift that
weight so I said okay two years pass
senior physio seeing the doctors no
nothing's helping so I was like okay I'm
gonna figure out my own way of doing
this so discovered some new things
um and just I started hanging on on like
a pull-up bar uh for about five sets of
30 per day and alhamdulillah that cured
my shoulder pain
um so I just I just decided to continue
down this path of uh pursuing Fitness
and doing a crap ton of push-ups doing a
bunch of like maybe two years ago I ran
like uh 50 kilometers with no training
whatsoever I ran from City to City so in
Kurdistan they they have two cities it's
called The Hook and Zoho
um I was trying to raise money for
Syrian refugees but the situation there
is pretty bad I was like you know I told
my friend hey I need you and your car
tomorrow you were we're going six seven
hours eight hours maybe whole day if we
need to and so he's like okay and we
decide to run literally like 50
kilometers at the end of it kind of
my mom's gonna see this but he he runs
me over kind of
um and he's going like he's going like
five miles per hour so he doesn't do
much damage I look at my feet I'm like
am I okay okay I'm good and then we just
continue the race and uh
there's a lot of stuff that I'm doing
that I'm just I don't I don't feel
comfortable just just chilling like when
I'm when I'm in my bed or or let's say I
sleep in one day I don't feel
comfortable when I don't work out when I
don't do something when I don't drop
down and do a couple hundred push-ups do
300 pull-ups that's the only time where
I feel kind of good to be honest
um wow okay so what do you say that this
this state of you know always feeling
like you need to be pushing yourself and
be working out and be you know bettering
yourself do you think that that's a good
thing or do you think that's it's it's
ever taken to an extreme
I mean my my parents would say that I'm
a bit extreme but siani the thing is
Romney like we're Muslims at the end of
the day we're trying we're here for
maybe 60 70 years we're gonna be here
and then we're gonna go we're we're here
for only a day you're part of the day
and whether it's good whether it's
extreme I think the people of back then
the prophet salallahu he would be
carrying a 20 20 kg of armor plate in
throughout the battle they would be
fasting throughout the battles
is the guy that when I listen to some of
the videos of his stories and how he
lived his life I want to be like him how
they were in battle I think there was a
time where they were gonna go they were
laying Siege to a to a village and this
Village
it kind of he just couldn't control
himself him and a couple of uh of sahaba
they went and in the middle of the night
they go in they kill a bunch of people
and they bust open can I say that on
YouTube they they Mark a couple people
if that needs the you know yeah and they
they open the gates uh at Treasure so
whether I'm going extreme I think the
human body adapts to whatever stresses
you put on it if you adapt yourself to
laying on a couch all day your muscles
and ligaments and tendons and bones are
going to be weak if you put 100 200
kilos obviously working up to that
you're gonna adapt to that so whatever
you put yourself in I feel like I listen
to my body some days I need rest but
other days I can some days I'm working
out four times a day Rami it's it's bad
and you know the reason I asked that is
because I I actually don't think you can
really take it to an extreme unless
you're hurting yourself and it's not
benefiting you anymore right like like
ego lifting like you mentioned or um
even the process of them he would stay
up all night in prayer but he would tell
others not to do that because his feet
would start cracking but he said oh you
know I'm the prophet of Allah so that's
for him to do for us we pray a shorter
amount of time we still praying so when
it when it comes to people pushing
themselves I think there's an extreme on
the opposite end where people just want
to be lazy and comfortable and sit on
the couch and you know why don't you
take three days rest it's like why do I
need that why do I need to take three
days rest and it's weird because you're
seen as an abnormality but
what's abnormal what is wrong with it
what's bad about it this is something
that that's amazing I wouldn't say
alhamdulillah
all strength comes from Allah like I've
had many injuries due to this uh extreme
level of activity however uh I do agree
with you I mean I think people are are
too soft nowadays they're too lazy
they're too complacent I think well
we're young men you and I I'm 22 I don't
know how old you are I'm 22 as well
you're 20. I love my bed we're young men
we have we have straight but we should
be conquering I don't we should be
conquering worlds bro we should we're at
the age where we have so much we have
literally unlimited energy if we want to
we can literally go off of eating
potatoes onions and water and we can
conquer something we can conquer
something yeah I mean we're built
psychologically for this as human like
when I take on more challenges you would
think that you'd get tired you would
think that you'd get more lazy but no uh
it it it your brain kind of goes into
overdrive mode when I was at the end of
my the 50 kilometer that is it's
basically an ultra marathon
um anything more than a marathon is an
ultra marathon so I mean I I do plan on
doing maybe 100 kilometers one day
inshallah but this is maybe in the
future uh but the thing is when I was at
the end of that at one point my brain
out in the middle of it I was kind of
tired I was like oh I'm done and then at
one point my brain just activated and
dude I was I was on it my brain was I
don't know it's it's something about the
human body it can push its it can
activate things that you didn't know you
had it can activate different levels of
your body so there there's like a base
level and then there's like a higher
level where I did a thousand push-ups
the other day
when I got around the 900 Mark doing at
first doing 20 push-ups was difficult
because my chest was just but then at
the 900 Mark I was just gasing them out
guessing them up yes in them out so I
think the human body can handle a lot
more than we actually think you know and
now I'm
good absolutely and I'm very glad you
said that because I think there's
multiple layers to it the human body not
just physically but you know mentally
emotionally people I think are capable
of handling a lot more than they think
and just them thinking that I'm not
going to be able to do this mentally
emotionally physically is what is you
know disabling them from being able to
do that thing like if you go to like I
the most I've ever done was a plate
right now I don't think I'm gonna be
able to do that but if I on a good day
back when I was working out if I would
go and say I'm gonna do this I have a
spotter obviously to just in case but
I'm like I'm going to do this Allah made
me strong I'm going to push this plate
and I bench press if I tell myself I'm
gonna do it back then I would do it but
if I look at like it's looking a little
heavy today man well I'm gonna give it
my best I'm like I'd like to die in a
second so it's it's there's a huge
psychological aspect to it and it
doesn't help that people are pushing
everyone basically do what pleases you
physically you know and unfortunately a
lot of people working out they don't
constitute that as pleasing them
physically so so it really puts them in
this regress State back when you posted
a video and um you know there's one we
spoke about on live it was a little bit
harsh some people thought
um
there was a time when it was not that
big of a deal using a word like that
people are thinking I'm going to talk
about the N word or the f word or
something crazy it's not it isn't hey
it's an NF word but not the f word you
know it's something that's so soft but
people are have turned into a phobia now
if you if you use that word which is
absolutely absurd um I made a video very
recently just um did you see that
Christian hijabi that was saying I
wouldn't marry a Muslim man because I
want my kids to be Christian now yeah I
made a video and all I said was like
when your kids hit nine years old and
they're given the choice of worshiping
one God or worshiping a three and one
God who was the son of God and God
himself and born through the woman that
he created they're probably gonna pick
the first one I got all these people
like oh so it's okay to disrespect
religions now and it's like what did I
do I'm literally just just making an
argument and I you can't even do that
these days you know of course these
couch potatoes are sitting there angry
at every little thing they have nothing
better to do we as men need to get up
and we need to work so how does a man
start how like I'm I'm a I'm a lazy
Couch Potato I'm seeing the stream I'm
motivated what do I do
what do you do so I mean back to that
point like I do agreement people people
really don't have much to do nowadays
they're lazy couch potatoes and they
will argue over no reason like like the
fat thing the fat to my fat you know
whatever I'm not gonna finish the rest
of it and and to that video of you
speaking about the hijabi you're
literally you're just saying your truth
you're saying what you believe to be
true and you'll find just random people
on the internet they don't know you I
bet you they wouldn't even say that to
your face if they saw you they would
just look at you oh that was that guy I
commented on this video I'm gonna he
wants the same to something but Allah
I don't want to say the word but he's
he's that he's he's he can't he can't do
that he's not he's not built for that
and I don't think many men are are
capable of that type of Confrontation so
to my lazy couch potatoes listen
you are you everything's your fault you
have become a lazy Couch Potato because
of you it is not because of my mom or my
dad bullied me or my dad abused me or
because I I won't I won't talk about my
family but it's been very rough growing
up I had a very tough childhood and I'm
so happy for it sometimes I look back at
it and you know it's not Middle Eastern
parents I'm I'm Kurdish Middle Eastern
parents aren't the best uh in terms of
traversing some families mine is uh and
and alhamdulillah
it's it's been a blessing that I've been
inflicted with this type of pain because
it's been able to get me out of my
comfort zone get out your damn comfort
zone okay you're waking up let's say at
12 p.m what are you doing waking up at
12 p.m you have seven hours before that
wake up for Fajr wake up early start the
morning early if you start the morning
early you're gonna the prophet salallahu
has I think he's made Dua for the people
in the beginning of the day go to the
Masjid go be go be a man I think back in
the ottoman Empires they would they
would know if a man was missing during
for the Salat for federal and they would
come and bring him they're like hey you
know like go knock on his door bring him
there so Yani as meant go and pray for
Fajr in the Masjid this is I'm not even
getting into the physical part okay go
and pray for you in the Masjid then the
sahaba will start their day off with the
Quran they go to the Masjid start their
day off with the Quran right after that
they would go into their livelihood go
to work out go to exercise whatever they
do throughout their daily lives go and
get an exercise like me this is my
schedule I wake up in the morning I'm
going prefajit and then some Quran and
then after that go and go and do
something physical go to the park I
don't care if it's cold if it's raining
that's good go in the rain and freaking
run go outside
I I try to avoid gyms because of the
fitness involved with them so I mean I
get it it's not Haram I wouldn't say it
I mean
I mean no any fat to what it said it
says I don't I just try to avoid the
fitness because of myself
go and work out okay what are you doing
there lazy bro imagine I'm on coaching
calls Rami I'm on coaching calls I'm
talking hey what are you trying to
accomplish I'm trying to lose his belly
fat okay why how did you gain it he's
like oh I got married I'm like
you got married this is more reason for
you to get into shape do you want your
wife to leave you you want because like
it's it's it's a false it's a sad
reality I know of a brother his wife
left him because he became complacent
after he got married like we're we're
working out we're training we're we're
getting becoming our best version and
then oh I get married my wife cooks good
food okay your wife cooks good food no
you're not exercising you're blaming it
on external factors know that everything
that you everything that befalls the
person is because of that person is
because of what what action that person
has done so you're not you're not a
skinny stick because your genetics I
mean maybe you are but yeah you can work
for it you can put on some muscle you
can you can go and trade you can do a
thousand push-ups 200 push-ups you can
go and Sprint up a hill and your body
activate uh agh to grow more muscle Yani
get up what are you doing there lazy the
prophet salallahu was even in his old
age he was 50 something he was carrying
a 20 kilogram weight like a armor armor
plate in the battle what are you doing
there lazy this is your profit he's 50
something
so the honey Brothers get up
stop being stop being complacent
it's very sad we don't have men in this
ummah we don't have and physicality is
one part of it it's it's getting there
as well it's also acting upon
and then
having the physical strength having the
financial means and then using it for
your Dean you know it's
it's more than just a a quick bicep Flex
it's you're you're benefiting the um
maybe you can go to Syria and help some
Syrian refugees maybe you can go to
Turkey and lift up some damn water
crates to help out the refugees over
there Wallah
so yeah 100 and I was actually just
gonna ask what if this couch potato
looks at you and he says why why do I
need to be strong why do I need to be
big why do I need to be resilient why
can't I just sit on my couch you know I
work uh five to eight hours a day I make
money I'm making a living and the rest
I'm just relaxing at home why do I need
to do all these extra things but I think
you kind of answered it towards the end
you know helping the ummah and
everything do you have any additional
reasons why you know a Muslim man needs
to be strong
the prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam
said the strong believer is more beloved
to Allah than the weak believer this is
not just in strength physically also it
is indeed it is in Iman but it's also in
strength physically so if you are a
stronger believer you'll be of more
benefit to the ummah if I'm okay
goodness gracious
shaytan doesn't want us to be strong bro
you need a stronger phone
oh he froze
it's okay
everything good yeah you're Frozen oh
okay I think it's good now now okay so
you know the strong believer is more
beloved to Allah than the weak believer
so this is Allah why would you not want
Allah to be to be born beloved to Allah
why would you not be more beloved to you
to your creator this is the this is the
prophet salallahu you look at um
these were strong men like holiday I
think when he he wrestled one time and
he ended up breaking his arm when they
were wrestling as he kind of dropped him
you know and it's a part of these are
he's a six foot four I think a strong
man and he was a great example to the
ummah he he was he would go out into
battle he well he would at the five
o'clock in the morning like four o'clock
in the morning before fajit he's just
itching itching for battle itching
I'm not saying that there weren't any
situation where this is happening or
occurring or because then you might go
and join Isis which I'm not condoning at
all and don't do that I've lost many
good brothers because of this because
they think there's Jihad going and
there's nothing going on but maybe one
day perhaps something may occur and
you're not ready you're a fat lazy couch
potato and what use are you yeah you
have Iman in your heart yeah you're
reciting your Quran but you also have to
have that you have to have that strength
you know yeah yeah 100 and you know I
love that Hadith because the first time
actually no I've heard that Hadith many
times and I want to explain it the way
my teacher explained it to me he said
you always hear either the beginning of
the Hadith or the end of the Hadith but
you never hear the full Hadith together
and he explained the full Hadith
together and I made literally I think
I've mentioned it so many times on this
part cast my own channel processarily he
says the strong believer is better and
more loved by Allah than the weak
believer and there is good in everyone
and then he said you know this kind of
begs the question by the way how do I
get strong you know it begs the question
how do I get strong the process enemy
says hold on tight to that which gives
you benefit
right and then he says don't lose your
heart so that Hill that's down the
street that you could run up and down 50
times that's something that can give you
benefit so you should take advantage of
it you know having a brother hewa you
know next door down at the park going
and training with him that's beneficial
watching this podcast this episode
taking notes listening to it in the
morning so you can become motivated that
is something you should hold on to
tightly because it gives you benefit
then the prophet saws he says and don't
become heartless don't become hopeless
don't lose your heart and then that begs
the question how would I lose my heart
he says if something comes to you in the
form of difficulty you know like you you
you you try and hit a new PR or whatever
and you can't do it and you're like man
why am I even doing I've been trying to
get this for three months and I can't I
should just give up across the setup
said no he said do not lose your heart
and if something difficult happens do
not say if you know man if only I did
this or that or blah blah whatever
whatever he said rather say called it
Allah and Allah does as he Wills because
saying if opens the door to the shaytan
then you go back to the top of the
Hadith strong believer is better and
more beloved to Allah than the weak
believer and you keep going and so on
and so forth so like he gives us the
full formula and how to get strong
you know we don't utilize it
unfortunately I'm gonna I'm gonna show
you Brothers okay let's say this is a 14
year old brother just watching this this
live this is how I began my journey
Brothers I'm telling you I was so weak I
couldn't even do I couldn't even do this
like I was literally just doing this
this is nothing for me now like
alhamdulillah I've gotten the strength
that Allah has given me I was literally
doing this daddy
just like going back to what you said
just because you're failing at it just
because it's it's going wrong just
because it's not going your way just
because you haven't you haven't received
the the the result doesn't like he's
like you know you can work really hard
you can try your best at the end of the
day Allah Allah controls everything
Allah controls all of the results
whatever is going to happen Allah is
going to allow that to happen all you
can control is how much work you put it
how much effort you put in so continue
to put in effort don't get disheartened
continue to work there were times where
I was I was so disheartened and and low
and I was like you know what despite
what I feel I'm just gonna continue with
this like the other day I go to I go to
this one boxing gym I'm learning how to
fight and I
well I worked out three times that day I
don't want to go and work out I don't
want to but I'm something's just inside
me it's just it's not it's not chilling
so I go to the gym
I'm lazy I'm just like this and my
body's just slippery droopy I just start
jump roping I just start jumping and
something hits my psyche it's like you
know you're out here while you don't
feel like it and people you're out here
while you don't feel like it and you're
putting in the work and you're putting
in the effort and so you will receive a
benefit and then alhamdulillah by the
end of the workout I was just moving so
literally just just start five minutes
tell yourself you're gonna do five
minutes Brothers if you can't if you
can't do a full workout just say you're
gonna do five minutes
five minutes is gonna pass by you're
gonna you're gonna end up sweating
you're gonna be and You're Gonna Wanna
Do more your body's gonna be activated
the endorphins are going to be rushing
and you're going to want to do more work
and it's going to feel really good so
just start the first five minutes now
100 very beautifully said and I think a
big roadblock people have is like
they're they're a skinny guy like like
me when I was younger and you and I'm
still skinny like don't get me wrong and
you when you were younger you know they
they envisioned working out the gym like
a huge buff guy like the size of a
Silverback yeah bench pressing like four
plates like it's nothing and they want
to get in the gym and even just like
look remotely similar to that but they
know when they get to the gym they're
going to be benching just the bar with
no weight on it and that's too much for
their ego to handle and they don't even
start because of that setting
expectations I think is one of the most
important things you need to know you're
not going to get to that state maybe
ever unless you really want to and you
work for it
and if you do it's going to take a long
time to get there half these people are
not even natural you know what they put
in their bodies for that but if your
intention is clean and you set the right
expectations and you start working
towards it even if it's a little bit
even if it's a little bit you will form
good habits and then those good habits
will basically show like it'll show you
the path it'll pave the path for you to
increase and do more and more and more
until you get to a level where it's just
this is your life you're strong enough
you're working to get stronger instead
of just you know bodybuilding you're
doing MMA and so on and so forth and
that's it Insha'Allah all because you
started here with a little bit of work
here and there
um one question that some people have
is what about the sisters you know
should the women work and be strong and
work out and all that stuff as well
no okay so it's a very good point that
you brought up I'll address what you
just said uh about you know incremental
changes you don't you when I when I
thought about somebody who studies
Islamic knowledge he doesn't go and
study the highest level of fit he
doesn't go and study other he doesn't go
and study like like these confusing
topics he starts with the Arabic
language so for you Brothers thinking
you're going to be this great Mountain
you're gonna after you do one bicep curl
or one session you're like looking in
the mirror you're noticing hey I'm
getting bigger right after that one
session it's a step-by-step thing I've
been doing this since I was 11 years old
I haven't been doing it what you guys
see on the screen is what I've done for
11 years 11 11 or so years so it's not
like a one day thing and you can you
know become the best at it it's it's
it's many years in the making it's it's
not like oh when am I going to get a
six-pack it's okay I'm gonna stay
consistent on this this should be your
mentality I'm gonna stay consistent on
this and in Shortline five six ten years
I should see good results make it a part
of your life so it's very good point you
brought up and for the Sisters my
sisters may Allah bless you guys I I
mean this in the best of
hearts
you want to take care of your health
first of first of all to please Allah
first of all your health should be for
the sake of Allah if you do plan on
getting married if you do plan on trying
to start a family understand that when
you let's say you decide to have kids
you have to be in shape so a good way to
start invest in like a five dollar jump
rope you that's your that'll be your
cardio you don't have to be running
around the street you know with your uh
we don't want to see that sisters we got
like a five a five dollar jump rope you
can jump rope inside the house you got
body weight workouts for days you got
you got literally all these Fitness
influencers on YouTube follow a long
workout you can do four days a week five
days a week six days a week
um it's the same thing for sisters eat
right I don't know if you unless you're
dealing with like PCOS which is like a
uh when I made that video a lot of
sisters said like I'm dealing with PCOS
um you know if you if you're not dealing
with any conditions you're perfect
perfectly healthy woman but you're just
overweight or you're underweight start
working out and start eating right
basically it's very simple this is
Fitness caloric deficit caloric Surplus
when I'm in a caloric deficit I'm going
to be losing fat you don't want to go to
two down a lot of sisters one thing
sisters that I see that you when I'm
coaching sisters I don't see you sisters
or I don't I don't really uh I'm not
seeing any of the sisters that I coach
one thing that I see wrong with them
Rami this is what they do bro they they
are eating a thousand calories a day
they could be five eight they're 180
pounds they're eating a thousand
calories a day sister we don't want you
to be skinny we want you to be healthy
we want you to like let's say you're
five eight hundred eighty pound woman
you're gonna need at least maybe two
thousand something calories you're gonna
need to eat good you're gonna need to
eat protein and inshallah you'll get
that uh hourglass figure that you're so
many sisters are looking for they're
looking for that you know that that
thing that they like and a bitmilla just
stay consistent upon it sisters if you
get disheartened
um foreign
very beautifully said I think for um for
men and women it's always gonna it's
always gonna shift because of the virtue
that they are a man or a woman for a man
the reason he has the way he has to be
strong and the reason he has to be
strong is going to be different than the
the way and reason a woman has to be
strong completely so I think going back
to Allah
your your role as a as a man as a
husband as a father as a woman as a wife
as a mother is you know you need to
focus on on that specifically
um so
I want to go back to the point that um
you had mentioned before and I want
people to just realize something and it
did it wasn't until I realized this that
I didn't really start pushing myself the
next three years are going to pass
so when you hear Brother who will say
that he's been doing this for the last
11 years or so
don't think man I didn't start 11 years
or so
that's the dumbest thing you could think
right now be wise the next 11 years are
going to pass so are you going to do
what our brother did are you gonna do
what you know David Goggins did are you
gonna do what the strongest men have
done
and say I'm gonna work now for the next
years 10 20 years and build myself up
are are you gonna let those next 10 20
years pass by and not do anything
because 20 years from now you're going
to look back and say man I wasted the
last 10 years yeah hell yeah you did so
you need to get up and start now and
plan because those years will pass
whether you're sitting on your butt or
you're in the gym working out or
learning Quran learning some you know
giving dawa improving people and
improving yourself in life inshallah
rum is right I mean don't look at my 11
years I mean I've I'm gonna do this for
inshallah if I can if I'm still able for
20 more years 30 more years 40 more
years until the day I die inshallah
because it's not it's not something that
I I'm doing for just the result I'm not
chasing results I'm not chasing oh I
need to reach this six-pack or I just do
it because it really feels good your
body the way that it's processed
processes are set up when you work out
you're releasing uh endorphins you're
releasing feel good hormones you're
you're you're activating
a lot of processes in your body that you
need to function to stay alive and stay
healthy I know some people they have
like I know a couple of close family
members they stopped working out they
they did soccer when they were younger
and then they stopped working out
whatsoever it's been 20 30 years and
subhanallah they got big bellies now
they can barely move their immobile so
it's like think about this you could you
could end up in a situation where
somebody's wiping your butt because you
didn't take care of your health you
didn't work out you you're in a diaper
you didn't take care of your health you
you it's it's it gets really bad so it's
not something that you should Chase for
aesthetic purposes and oh this guy is
lean and shredded it's it's healthy it's
good to be healthy it's good to be able
to move and walk around by yourself and
not need a walker by the time you're 30
40 years old because a lot of one thing
that I I kind of stopped when I was
maybe 20 years old I stopped training
like an athlete I was just training like
a bodybuilder and I lost my ability to
jump and run I started training to jump
and run again now I'm the most athletic
I've ever been you can always when
you're 20 when you're 30 you can still
run you can still Sprint you can still
jump you just have to work through it
progressively progressively
progressively and be Nila you know it's
uh it's it's a good thing to do one one
I want to bring up one point let's say
you decide to get married let's say you
have a spouse you have one spouse let's
say there's two spouses two options you
have one spouse
they're taking care of their health
they're working out they're eating right
they're doing everything they're working
out an hour a day they're eating their
the steak they're eating the eggs
they're eating the protein everything
that's necessary and then you have
another option they're not working out
they're lazy they they only chase after
doing your things like you're just
working a job they're working a job and
they don't do anything besides working
that job they're not they're sitting
down in an office all day they're eating
that's a good one they're eating
terrible Foods I was going to say
something they're eating terrible Foods
they're eating foods that aren't the
best for them which one would you think
has more respect for themselves
the one that's eating Ryan working out
and all that stuff yeah the one that's
eating right ayani I think there's a
there's a hobby who said I like to
beautify myself just as I'd like for my
wife to beautify himself was it
but there was a hobby that said this
like he likes to beautify himself just
as he would like for his wife to
beautify herself for him so it's it's
not like oh I don't have to do this for
a man or or a man I shouldn't have to
beautify myself and a man should accept
me if your man was broke you would leave
him you would leave him sister if he was
broken he was fat and he was ugly and
you would leave him at the inevitably so
you should try to strive to
preserve your marriage you should try to
strive to preserve yourself for your
partner because
your health is not just for you it's
also for your others if you can't move
and be mobile and be strong how are you
going to help your mother when she's 80
years old how are you going to help your
father when when he's 80 years old how
are you going to help your wife when
she's bedridden how are you going to
help your husband when he's better at it
it's it's preparing for situations that
will occur in your life
100 absolutely and you can see how many
people this resonates with for example
our brother here he says my 27 just flew
and I regret missing out on the last
four years of life and we also have uh I
don't know if his brother or sister says
it's a lifestyle that absolutely is and
look our brother here he said I found
huge improvements after four months so
you know someone like like brother Mark
here who again he says it's never too
late brothers and 25 but just take my
advice don't waste your 20 smoking weed
and not taking risk and all that stuff
100 but regardless whether you're 20 30
or 40 it's not too late
our brother found good results after
four months you know and I could say the
same now does that mean everyone's gonna
see noticeable results after four months
maybe maybe not Allah depends on what
you're doing and how efficient you're
working and all that stuff but you will
see results and it's not going to take
you you know 11 years to see results
it's going to take you 11 years to get
to a certain point but you're gonna see
amazing results and be better and better
along the way and I think I think it
gets to a point where when a person
looks at themself and they're proud of
themselves you know in the mirror that's
when those negative thoughts go away
once they get some people Unfortunately
they develop some kind of like bodies
this dysmorphia I think is what it's
called and they're never satisfied but
in child life you don't suffer from that
I think you'll hit a point where you
look at yourself you're proud of
yourself you're inspired to keep going
and there's no more negative thoughts of
oh you know I'm weak I don't look good
and all that stuff you just gotta push
yourself to get there inshallah and to
add on to that this the body dysmorphia
it's a very good point you find a lot of
brothers or sisters they'll compile
compare themselves to what they see on
social media social media is a big trap
I know models some models I used to I
was gonna go and do some modeling
alhamdulillah I left that uh
terminated that for me I was gonna go
and model in New York some of these
models they fast for five days until
they're ready for a photo shoot wow
these Fitness they fast water fast
they're drinking water just drinking
water I've tried a three-day water fast
around me and I'm telling you bro you
get so freaking lean and and your
stomach it shrinks down a lot so what
you see on social media it's it it is
it's real but it's it's not something
that you should compare yourself to you
should the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam when he would he would he said
like look to those who have less than
you if you want to be grateful look to
those who have less than you always look
at those who aren't maybe somebody's
shorter than you and alhamdulillah you
don't have that maybe somebody's father
you're not that so always look to those
who are less than you and don't compare
yourself to those who have more than you
and I also wanted to bring up a very
good point Rami which is why you and I
are here and why I I think maybe you
guys have started the three Muslims but
it's Brotherhood Brotherhood and
Sisterhood we need you need to find a
group of brothers who are trying to
improve themselves if you're hanging out
the prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam
said you are upon the religion of your
friend whatever your friend's doing
that's what you're gonna do I have
friends and companions the only time we
ever meet up either is the Masjid or
it's hey let's go catch this workout
let's go play soccer let's go do this
let's let's go do some boxing let's go
do some wrestling let's go do some
calisthenics whoever your friends are
who make good companions try to find
some brothers who are trying to improve
their improve their lives don't hang out
with brothers who are smoking weed
they're chilling here smoking cigarettes
they're in the street life I've known
I've known so many brothers who have who
have lost their lives to in the streets
just smoking selling things like that
and it's it's very sad because I see
them I'm a lot more grown now and I see
them and I'm like man they're living
very sad life so hang out with hang out
with some people who you would love to
be at your janaza who would you who
would you who you would love to when
when you are gone these are people that
would they would give Southern call on
your behalf they would they would take
care of your children they would take it
like
make friends with those types of people
and hang out with brothers who are
working out getting physically fit
yeah
100 very very beautifully said
um and there's many Hadith actually you
know correlating with that so the
prophet sallam he mentioned that being
alone is better than bad company but
good company is better than being alone
he had also mentions
basically uh a parable or an analogy of
a person who's friends with a um a
blacksmith they're always going to smell
like smoke even if they you know they
don't really go to the shop they're just
around him they're gonna smell like
smoke as well versus someone who sells
perfumes and all that stuff they're
gonna smell like perfumes and all taught
in really nice smells just from being
around that person so it's the same with
your friends and your habits and like
for example if you were to hang out with
people who swear a lot you will most
likely start swearing but if you are a
person who swears a lot and you hang out
people who don't then you're my most
likely gonna begin minding your your
language we have one super chat here
from Brother Muhammad he says
movement is watching
London coming after you it's some
brothers in London they kind of inspired
me to begin like calisthenics and things
like that and alhamdulillah they're very
good Brothers I would love to catch a
workout with them inshallah we'll go
maybe Rami you could come too as well
inshallah we could go to London catch it
have you seen those Brothers doing the
muscle ups and stuff bro inshallah that
would be sick but I have to learn how to
do a muscle up first inshallah easy
money
that's my next goal do a muscle up
inshallah and I want everyone to hold me
accountable to that
I'll be your coach
so you do offer coaching by the way
right no perfect so let's say your
brother is ready you know he has money
to spend and he wants to get fit and he
needs a coach how do they reach you
shoot me a DM on Instagram Insha'Allah
if you're interested in transforming
your body if you want to lose weight put
on muscle get more athletic fix your
back pain fix you I've helped a lot of
brothers alhamdulillah with their knee
pain with weight loss so if you're
interested inshallah shoot me a DM I
help sisters as well and sisters don't
worry I don't see you in any form or any
fashion and nor will I ever ask for
pictures from you then my kids
someone's doing some like Mighty workout
in the Next Room bro the whole family
so you guys heard it here first you guys
know to find Michelle but regardless of
what route you take just make sure it's
a good one make sure you're working on
yourself set reasonable goals or if if
you if you don't know where to start
just get yourself at a place where
you're exercising working out whether
it's a walk a run jumping rope like
brother he was sad going to the gym
doing push-ups going to the park
whatever it is as long as it's within
the realm of what Allah allows and it's
beneficial push yourself inshallah I
wanted to address something yeah to the
brothers specifically Brothers men were
the men of this um
when they were a month A month's
distance away from the enemy that's when
the enemy was started to shiver they
were scared they were terrified they
were scared of the of the Muslims
obviously first because of their Imam
the Iman was
but another thing they were physically
dominant yeah I mean they were you see
Brothers nowadays they got beer bellies
you see Brothers nowadays they're not
working out not doing nothing they're
skinny Brothers
you'll be you'll be working out
inshallah we'll get you on a program but
Nani you got brothers who are not
training at all they're not doing
anything they're not trying to improve
their themselves physically the kofora
laughing at us they're laughing oh look
at the look at the the Kurdish people oh
they got big like like we need to be
physically dominant we need to be
dominant first of all physically
financially knowledge in all forms in
all aspects we need to we need to when
somebody sees a Muslim they're like
that's a Muslim like you see you see his
muscles he's he's you maybe you don't
even see his muscle he's wearing a throw
but he's just looking like this and
another thing you don't have to be big
there are some people that I go through
this boxing gym some Muslim Brothers
model they're smaller than me they're
very small but bro when they're they're
sparring they are Dynamite they are
Dynamite they're very scary so take up
take up learn how to fight learn how to
shoot a gun learn how to learn how to
train yourself so that inshallah
whatever situation whatever thing you're
ready you're a soldier you're ready
you're ready to handle it you know
that's beautifully said bro beautifully
said honestly I'm I've the whole time
I've been telling myself throughout this
podcast I'm gonna go to the gym after
this I'm gonna go to the gym after this
uh that I think is a very beautiful
thing
um and you know subhanallah people some
people are like threatened not I want to
I want to address this comment honestly
I don't feel violated honestly I feel
very motivated and that's I think that's
the thing with like with with men
especially men who low-key are con like
motivated to work when a guy comes to
them and says you know what the hell are
you doing bro you sitting on your butt
it motivates men you know you can't talk
to women like that obviously don't talk
to women like that but when you talk to
a guy like that it motivates him
alhamdulillah I'm honestly very honest
that I I am here for this podcast but
people sometimes are are like worried or
scared that Muslims want to be on top
and even Muslims who have the thought of
oh I want to be on top they think well
that's a gray area I don't want them to
think that I'm a crazy person and I want
power and whatever because there's a lot
of bad stuff tied to Muslims in Islam
for really ridiculous reasons forget all
that the reason we want to be on top is
because we know a world run by Muslims
is a just world it's a fair world it's a
good world the prophetam he mentioned
that when the khilafa comes back and I
believe after the time of Imam Mahdi
comes and all that stuff there will be
such peace and Justice on the earth that
a female Shepherd a female Shepherd does
not have to worry about anything except
a wolf
eating one of her sheep so she doesn't
have to worry about being harassed or
call even cat called you know let alone
something egregious or horrible she
doesn't have to worry about someone
stealing her sheep or or anything like
that nothing
just an animal maybe attacking one of
her sheep that's it and that is under
the rule of the Muslims you know there
is a time when Muslims were powerful
they are at the top they were strong you
know conquering places like the brother
mentioned they are conquering places and
you know a week a week men makes a weak
society makes a an unproductive society
makes whoever is in power stay in power
because there's no competition
um and I mean
do you really just want to live in this
unjust world and one one more no
actually this is why or one of the
reasons shirk is the worst thing because
people think and I see the confused look
in your face I'm glad you have it
because it shows people don't understand
what you know what constitutes uh shirk
as well or what you know constitutes
um
um what's it called
disobeying Allah
right could be could be in some cases a
form of of disbelief a form of kuffer
for example if somebody says
that you can drink nothing wrong with it
it's not a problem it's completely Halal
there's no issue with it and you know
Allah says it's Haram you know for a
fact Allah says and you decide he says
it's Halal I'm gonna listen to him I'm
not going to listen to Allah
you've just left Islam if you said that
with full intention
with no ignorance
you know what you did you just left the
step so when a person this believes in
Islam they end up creating a system that
creates depressed sad suicidal couch
potatoes who are not willing to get up
to even work against any Injustice
that's going on in the world so the
people that created the corrupt Society
get the benefit from the corrupt Society
While most of the people that are
suffering are just suffering and there's
nothing they could do about it Islam
when you fully obey Allah you're you're
it's not an easy life by the way it's
not you're creating a full system where
you're working and striving for the sake
of Allah giving you know two and a half
percent of what you save which for some
people could be a lot to charity
um you know you're you're out you're
guarding you're in the Army for every
man it's obligatory that he fights if
there is a war like it's not an easy
thing but it's the most correct thing
because it leads to a just world or just
society and a society of advancement and
progression the goal of his age of Islam
came right after the expansion of Islam
when all these people came to Islam they
are motivated
to do basically the opposite of what
Europe was doing they were enter
fighting West in Eastern Europe were
fighting with each other very little
technological advancements the Muslims
had literally everything legislation
philosophy
um science math Optics like all these
fields and it came from strong willing
people through the religion of Allah and
hope inshallah we can get back there I
know I went on a bit of a monologue
forgive me for that
very all very good points
basically like we are in need of men we
are we are in a like I know sisters that
would rather marry they'd rather be a
second wife to a real man they'd rather
be a third wife a fourth wife to a real
man than a uh what What's what we have
today what we have we have couch
potatoes we have people that are lazy
well we we are so much in need of men
Yani
the only thing that's stopping the the
people that are corrupt the only thing
that's not that's allowing them to
have disruption and to cause this all
this stuff that's going on in the
western these societies and why people
are being killed is because people are
not
being met the men are not being met the
men are are are too busy occupied with
pornography they're too busy occupied
with Dunya they're too busy occupied
with this and that and the other
they're they're gaming they're they're
they're here level honestly I hate
gaming so much because it's it's it's
not productive okay yeah there's studies
where it'll increase hand-eye
coordination so what you're not leveling
up in real life you're you can go out
here and Conquer an actual Nation but
you're sitting there conquering a fake
world because they want you to stay here
they want you to stay in that weak place
and buy five thousand dollar PCS and
waste all your money on your uh little
electrical they want you to waste your
money on that because they know that if
if you leave that stuff if you get up
and you and you stand up and say okay
I'm gonna be a man and I'm gonna I'm
gonna uplift this Dean and I'm gonna
seek knowledge upon it and I'm gonna
make sure that in my lifetime I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm my family will be upon the
Quran
there will be a big community of people
in the Quran and verily the Muslims will
be victorious but the reason why we're
stuck is because we're not willing to
we're not willing to take the blame
we're not willing to say it's my fault I
personally
there was a brother who made the speech
and Allah it it makes me so angry it
pisses me off he said the reason why
that sister and that Siri that sister in
Syria who's getting raped by soldiers
and of excuse my language the reason why
is because men are not being met the
reason why is because people are not
taking responsibility this ummah is one
body this and we're sick we have cancer
well we have we have cancer we have
Ebola we have the worst of diseases and
we need to understand that the only way
we're gonna uplift this um if we if we
start taking responsibility if we start
seeking knowledge of this Deen and then
acting upon that date and then acting
upon that knowledge that we have learned
not just reciting and studying and
acting upon it if I learned something
I'm going to act upon it I'm going to
raise my family upon it and then corrupt
OS
these pedos that run this Society they
will be they will be destroyed
inshallah I mean even if you look like
the past 200 years even like America
they were fighting actual Wars they were
fighting against you know uh 1940
Germany I don't know what happened in my
camera they're fighting against 1940
Germany you know they they were working
they're striving they're struggling now
what's the face of their liberalism
what's the face of their liberal it's
the LGB you know the rest of it that's
what they're fighting for that's their
that's their fight
come on man I'm sorry that's the if they
don't get taken out to buy another
country
that's pushing a lot more masculine
values
I'm gonna be surprised but like that's
where they're heading now
Muslims are not going to take that route
inshallah we have a super chat from
Brother Sam here he says Sam Brothers
what died what do you what diet would
you suggest for me a 19 year old uh man
with type 1 diabetes may Allah bless you
for everything you do type 1 diabetes is
a lot more complicated than type two
um
I would recommend speaking to your
doctor seeing what you can have and what
you can't have
um try looking into the carnivore diet
dude try it try looking into the
carnivore diet for something like that
I've seen really good results I've heard
a lot of anecdotal benefits of people
taking the carnivore diet seriously I've
tried it myself and Romney I'm gonna
tell you bro eating straight meat and
eggs and protein and honey it changed me
mentally it changed I did it for like a
week but I couldn't do it it's just it's
very stressful
um but I've heard a lot of a lot of
anecdotal benefits for people trying
carnivore diets that's anecdotal and
there's there's also a lot of
cardiologists that speak of the benefits
of the the carnivore diet so try that
maybe test out different things and
don't give up just like Rami said you
know if there's a benefit in something
don't don't leave off don't leave it off
100 and even better those were the words
of the Prophet sallallahu
all right so I think that we're coming
to the end of the stream I would go
longer but now I really just want to go
to the gym uh so I feel uh I feel bad
staying here one comment I won't make is
actually I was out with the brother
yesterday may Allah bless him and he
mentioned this game where
um it it's basically I think from like
like the between the the the seventh and
like I don't know 18th century or
something like that where
uh basically you can take on different
armies and basically expand your kingdom
and if you decide to be like the Ottoman
Empire and rule over a certain area that
place would become basically under the
Islamic banner and all that stuff and
I'm like if I were to play a game like
that and work for years and like conquer
the earth I would feel so bad about
myself because I'm like I should be
doing this in real life and I'm sitting
playing this game and conquering you
know these virtual people and but he did
make a fair point that this is based on
actual history so you do learn a lot
while you do it which is fair but
regardless I like I would feel really
bad about myself if I played this game
and I conquered the whole world and
established like a Islamic uh caliphate
over the world in this game you know
because I'm like I should be doing this
in real life man yeah yeah I mean the
thing is another thing I wanted to bring
up also like I'm totally with you like
if you spend five years imagine on a on
a game on on a tablet on your phone
you're just scrolling and conquering it
yes you might might learn a thing or two
but who's whose fact check this history
who who know who knows that this is what
actually happened and what actually
occurred maybe you might discover oh
maybe the autumns had this type of
architecture but other than that Yani
I I would say Brothers go and seek
knowledge of your Dean surround yourself
with good Brothers Yani the reason like
what Rami what he was saying when when
Brothers speak to each other like this
we feel motivated when my brother says
I'd whoop you wrestling you well okay
let's go let's go to the mat yeah this
is men need to understand competition
feels good it feels amazing it feels if
you feel most alive when when your
brother's there he's he's doing 100
push-ups and you're trying to catch up
with him I have some sometimes I'll show
up late to a workout he's like I'm over
at 50 when you come on and I'm like oh
okay and then I'll go and I'll just rep
my thing in because as men we need to be
competitive it feels good it feels our
drive if you have other brothers it's
going to increase your testosterone no
doubt about it testosterone gets
increased when there's a competition
when there's no competition testosterone
drops when when everything's simple and
you're you're playing Ottoman Empire on
your phone testosterone drops but when
you're there actually with your brothers
you're you're there wrestling grappling
I was would say sparring but don't Spar
to the face don't hit to the face
sparring you're this is gonna it's gonna
build a level of okay I'm gonna get over
my brother because you have to you it's
it's innately in men's
biology and psychology we just love
competition when we get into it
sometimes Romney I go to the boxing gym
I'm so excited I'm just I'm just ready
to punch to do this head off I'm so
excited a lot so
the brothers that are like oh this guy
is too competitive go and be competitive
with your brothers but why do we play
sports why do we play soccer why do we
why are all these industries
multi-billion dollar Industries because
men love competition men loved don't
watch personally me I hate watching
sports I love playing them because I'm
actually doing something I think sports
are one of the oh Ronaldo Messi oh I
don't care about all that to be honest I
I don't I would I mean yeah they're cool
and all that but it's not benefiting go
out and actually be competitive don't
look at up to this guy look up to
holiday memories
because Allah is pleased with them and
you want to be like them and they were
very competitive especially
100 very beautifully said and you might
have the off person that's like oh why
would I want to be like these people a
thousand years ago they're like you know
barbaric and we're civilized now and
we're blah blah blah and there's give
and take with everything there's give
and take you can look at them as
regressed and they don't have the
technology we do and whatever but they
were strong imagine you were put in that
Society you would get swept off in like
like point four seconds you know you
would be done in like three seconds bro
yeah so it's like there's a given to
take yeah they didn't have technology
but they had everything they needed do
you have everything you need you can't
even get off the couch you know to
answer that why would I want to be like
them Allah says in the Quran
they are pleased with Allah and Allah is
pleased with them
so why would you not want to be like
somebody who Allah is pleased with who
and they are pleased with Allah why not
why would you not like to be from
amongst the best of example of this of
this of this ummah why would you not
like to be like the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam I remember in one battle
when he he was in the battle
nobody was with him he was alone he was
walking forward as they're firing arrows
I'm the prophet of Allah I am the
prophet of
bro that just brings chills down my
spine like it's it's like these were men
but now nowadays you have brothers oh
I'm too lazy to do this oh you want to
go on a run it's raining
get up Brothers we need men wallahi we
need men
100 you know what you just made me think
of something good I want everyone to
count every single time from this moment
on every single time you make an excuse
count it that excuse oh it's raining
count that as a damn excuse and write it
down somewhere every single time you you
know you should do something good and
you come up with some stupid excuse I'm
not feeling it or I'm tired or I worked
out yesterday
just remember that that's a freaking
excuse write it down somewhere count
them the amount of times you make an
excuse and compare it to the amount of
times you take action based on I should
work out today whatever count it and
then weigh it out inshallah and I'm
going to start doing that for myself as
well you're identifying the the negative
thoughts those those thoughts that
you're identifying the soft voice in you
and I want you I I add a challenge to
you brothers or and sisters I got for
sisters we'll just added squats you got
500 squats if you're a sister and you
got 500 squats if you're a brother I
mean 500 push-ups if you're a brother
if you can't do this know that your nafs
has defeated you you've allowed your
nuts to defeat you will you let you
enough defeat you
all right all right and yes I do take
that personally song uh I'm gonna take
on that Challenge 100 I'll update you uh
personally afterwards we'll be on a call
we're we're pressing push-ups we're like
I'm not playing let's do it let's make
it FaceTime as well let's do it
you have time do you have time I I mean
I I was thinking of going to the gym but
yeah I think this is inshallah just as
good
for joining us Iron Man himself may
Allah bless you Allah we have 300 people
in here that means we should have at
least 10 000 likes Insha'Allah so hit
the like button subscribe share this
video to a brother and a sister who
needs it with that being said brother do
you have any final words before we end
the Stream
we need men so the brothers we need men
and to the women we need women everybody
fulfill your role in bid Nilla in the
next life we'll see our rewards
and with that being said